[Music]
it's a fair bet we'll
only beat the coronavirus once most of
the globe is immunized
dozens of countries have started
vaccinating but hundreds are yet to
begin
the slow and bumpy roll out will only
allow the disease to continue
circulating
and delay hopes of eradication
new variants of covert 19 could also
erase progress
will the world get its act together fast
enough
well israel is way ahead in vaccinating
its people
over three and a half million and
counting the palestinians have a longer
wait
another case of inequality more on that
topic with a doctor in a moment
first this report from dw's tanya kramer
nurse mali mikhaili and her team work
almost around the clock to administer
the biontech pfizer vaccine
here in batim a town south of tel aviv
about 150 000 people are being
vaccinated daily
throughout the country
i really believe in this vaccine i also
got it and this week i get the second
dose
we didn't have then god any allergic
reactions
it's like a flu shot it is a very gentle
vaccine
it's good
the cultural center turned makeshift
vaccination point is run by clarit one
of israel's four
health management organizations which
provide care through their own clinics
as every citizen has to be registered
with an hmo
using the highly digitalized
infrastructure has proven decisive for
the fast rollout
first priority were people over the age
of 60
healthcare workers and people with
underlying health conditions
now it is the turn of the over 50s
it's great i didn't even feel the shot
i work as a special needs teacher and we
are all kind of in the line of fire
it's an absolute must to be vaccinated
younger people are also called up to
receive surplus doses of the vaccine
which would otherwise be wasted
the early purchase of the biontec visa
vaccine by the government has
contributed to this speedy immunization
campaign
however coronavirus infection rates are
still high
and the government tightened the
country's third lockdown once again
last week one challenge is vaccinating
and
earning enough time so the vaccines will
start to work and on the other hand we
have the
third the third wave in israel which has
been rising and the huge number
of uh severely sick people hospitalizing
the hospitals
ramallah in the israeli-occupied west
bank
a covit 19 testing center infections
remain high as well
but here people will have to wait to
receive their vaccines
israel has not been supplying vaccines
to the occupied territories
the palestinian authority announced this
week that it has signed deals with four
companies to secure vaccines
among them also the russian-developed
vaccine sputnik
in the news they say it is not yet
approved and they want to give it to us
we don't know what will happen
but at the end we hope that we will get
the appropriate vaccine
and we will be done with this crisis
we want all of us to take it to feed
psychologically at ease because we are
in a constant state of worry
and they will have other options
palestinians have also signed up to the
kovacs program
which aims to help low-income countries
to get a fair share of vaccines for
around 20 percent
of their population estee garrity is
chief medical officer
at esri a software company that offers
mapping and analytics
in the us how vital is a concerted
global drive in vaccinating the world
and
stopping this pandemic
it's incredibly important there's
actually a slogan
in global health that says no one is
safe until
everyone is safe and this is really an
indication
of our highly mobile and highly
interconnected world
recognizing that we depend on
international trade and we have travel
patterns
and if we want to get back to those
pre-covered travel patterns
and avoid an unrelenting progression of
the pandemic
the vaccine is our best hope and when we
can't look at it
as individual countries we need to do it
in a global way
we we need to asti but there is so much
inequality in the world and
in this case the the inequity is so
clear be it the palestinians
africans the super rich paying to to
jump the queue
how can we change that
well i personally think that uh taking a
geographic
approach is one way to really
hone in on these problem areas that
aren't getting the resources because
when you look at this geographically you
can spot those in equities
and you can start to do things about it
so
there are of course uh organizations
around the world from
gavi uh managing kovacs in coordination
with the world health organization
that are using geography to really
try to equalize what's going on how
exactly are they doing that can you just
explain to our viewers what all that
means
sure what they're doing is they're
creating of course
the plants they're called micro plans
really looking at places
on that in a way microscopic level when
you're sort of thinking about the globe
and they're figuring out how we can look
at the populations
and their access to vaccine and then
provide
resources in the places where there's
not adequate access
and it tells you a lot about how much
vaccine should you order for different
places
when you understand where the population
is and where
the vaccine distribution sites are
proposed or already in place so i guess
that also applies to
uh within countries the difference
between cities and and the countryside
or remote areas for example
absolutely so geography is particularly
helpful with that because you can look
at things like
high-risk populations and what their
level of accessibility is whether you're
measuring that
as say a 30-minute drive time or in some
places it's more likely that people are
going to be walking or
taking public transportation so you can
really define
what kind of access that local
population will need
and then when you identify where you
have gaps in access
you can start to make different plans
those different plans
might be a drive-through vaccination
clinic
or working with independent pharmacies
or
fire stations or schools or
other community locations that can serve
the local population
you can also do things like create
mobile outreach and
optimize the routes of maybe a mobile
van
to vaccinate highly rural populations or
folks who are unlikely to come to a
clinic to get their vaccine
but even if you identify those gaps
is there going to be enough vaccine for
everybody
well i think the answer to that is
absolutely yes
but a more poignant question perhaps
is how long is it going to take and the
estimates right now
are that through 2021 there should be
about 2 billion doses of vaccine
made available to the world so since
most of the vaccines require
two shots to be a full series that means
about a billion people can be vaccinated
in 2021
well that only represents about 13 of
the world's population so
i think this is going to take several
years to accomplish but yes
ultimately there will be enough and once
everyone's vaccinated
will that mean the coronavirus has been
eradicated
uh well we would hope so but i don't
think so so it's the vaccine
basically stimulates your body to
create an immune response and that
immune response has a memory so that
when you're ultimately exposed to the
vaccine
you can fight it more quickly and
effectively
but that memory fades over time and
current predictions say you know if
we're lucky two to three years of
protection but more likely
we'll need an annual booster to kind of
remind our immune system
what it's supposed to be fighting okay
we'll have to leave it there estee
garrity thank you very much good talking
to you
my pleasure thank you and now it's your
turn to ask the questions our science
correspondent derek williams has been
looking into the topics you've been
posting on our youtube channel
if you contract the virus after the
first shot in a two-shot vaccine
do you still need the booster shot this
turned out to be a really
tricky question because it's so specific
and and different types of vaccines
uh work in different ways to zero
in on an answer though it makes sense to
start with something
general what vaccines do which is to
provoke
an immune response vaccines basically
kick-start that process by faking
an infection but it takes time for the
body
to get up to speed and start making the
right defensive cells
to fight off the intruder trials with
vaccines approved
in the u.s and the eu for example have
shown that the first
jab does provide some protection against
developing symptoms of covid19
if you're exposed but it takes more than
10 days to get there and
and it's only around 50 percent
effective
much less than when boosted by the
second
shot given the specified few weeks after
the first one
so here's the scenario you described you
got the first shot
of your vaccination and then you were
exposed to covet 19
say a day or two later and ended up with
symptomatic disease because
your immune system hadn't ramped up the
response yet
the centers for disease control in the
u.s says that
if that's the case it's important to
defer
your second shot until you've recovered
so i
assume that means even if that takes
longer than the window of time
recommended between the first shot and
the booster
a few other sources i could find on this
specific question
recommended definitely getting the
booster shot
once you've recovered anyway as the
expectation is
it'll do no harm and will likely
actually
strengthen your immune response to the
coronavirus
if you encounter it again in the future
you